[Musica]
bene e avete sentito avete sentito più
volte il coraggio delle idee l'avete
sentito in sanità in medicina il
coraggio delle idee è generato dalle
esperienze per questo vi voglio
raccontare una
storia perché in medicina ci sono tanti
ragazzi che forse diventeranno medici
sono medici e diventeranno medici per
alcuni eventi e la storia che vi
racconto È quella di un cardiologo di un
medico che a Catanzaro 23 anni fa era un
famoso professore
universitario si si sveglia una
mattina sente un
peso enorme al petto al
torace il braccio sinistro gli fa male
respira con
difficoltà e beh per un medico Non è
difficile pensare che non è che è
un'indigestione
immediatamente capisce che c'è qualcosa
che non funziona va nel suo policinico
era un famoso professore aveva una bella
moglie due figli adorabili una bella
casa e un futuro radioso va al
Policlinico e purtroppo questo
cardiologo muore 3 ore dopo per
infarto e a quel tempo al policrinico
non non esisteva l'emodinamica non
esisteva una
cardiologia non esisteva
questo straordinario device questo
strumento semplice che si chiama
stent questo questa protesi ha salvato
migliaia di vite umane molte di più di
quanto ne ha salvato il
vaccino E che cosa quindi è importante
oggi è importante
l'economia è
importante
la la vita il benessere oggi la cosa più
importante che abbiamo imparato dal
covid è soprattutto la prevenzione e la
cura delle
malattie però Esiste un
problema vi ricordate la questione
meridionale dell'economia vi ricordate
la FIAT che costruiva le Panda a Torino
e poi le vendeva in cabria bene oggi
esiste una questione meridionale della
sanità e qualche cosa che interessa
soprattutto le regioni del sud
e la domanda è in Cabre si può fare
buona
sanità il sistema sanitario Nazionale
che era un lanto per la nostra nazione
sistema che veniva chiamato universale
perché tutti potevano accedere alla cura
e alla diagnosi delle malattie È stato
come sapete ignorato per 10 anni dalla
politica dalla politica di destra e di
sinistra per 10 anni la sanità è stata
considerata una
spesa Poi è arrivato un Tsunami del
covid E beh il covid ha messo ha fatto
ha deciso le priorità ci ha fatto capire
che l'economia è importante ma senza la
sanità senza il benessere la salute
dell'uomo l'economia non è più
importante alla fine della storia se
esiste un benessere
economico senza la te
ebb questo serve a poco
e in Calabria si
vive di più O si vive Meno qual è la
mortalità in Calabria per le martie del
cuore bene Qui vedete il numero di morti
di persone che muoiono per malattie
cardiovascolari in Italia muoiono 32
persone ogni
10.000
abitanti e come è messa la Calabria è
messa male vedete Calabria Sicilia e
Campania sono le tre nazioni le tre
regioni del sud dove la mortalità per
Marti del pure è più
alta ma si dice che i calabresi sono
ospitati che hanno il è buono ma come
vedete abbiamo una mortalità
estremamente
alta voglio farvi vedere una foto Questa
è una foto importante per me una foto di
25 anni fa qui Vedete un grande
cardiologo il professor Chiarello qued
con la freccia che un giorno mi chiamò
Io ero tornato da poco negli Stati Uniti
Avevo già aperto due emodinamiche in
Italia e mi raccontò la storia che vi ho
detto quel medico era un suo grande
amico mi disse bisogna aprire in
Calabria una cardiologia
moderna E quando sono venuto qui in
Calabria 22 anni fa questo è stato il po
critico che ho visto vi Devo confessare
che ho avuto un animo un attimo di
sbandamento
era una struttura fatiscente fatiscente
non solo per quella che era la struttura
del policinico ma fatiscente perché
mancava un emodinamica mancava un'
elettrofisiologia mancava tutto quello
che ci voleva per una cardiologia
moderna in Calabria lo abbiamo sentito
prima tutto è difficile Ci vuole come
abbiamo detto la forza delle idee e
tutto è difficile quando si comincia da
questa
situazione una situazione drammatica non
c'era
l'aspirina poi siamo stati fortunati
perché nel
2008 ad opera del più grande rettore che
è l'Università della Magna Grecia Uto il
professor
venuta Abbiamo costruito un campus che è
molto simile a un campus americano e
grazie a questa struttura innovativa
siamo stati capaci di portare avanti un
progetto innovativo una cardiologia
moderna ed
efficiente ho visto che in sala molti
avete report Watch bene una buona
notizia per voi il nostro gruppo ha
scoperto per primo che è possibile fare
oggi la diagnosi di
infarto utilizzando lo smart watch e
questo consente di fare una diagnosi
tempestiva perché il segreto della
sopravvivenza dei pazienti con l'infarto
è appunto una diagnosi quanto più
precoce possibile così in questi anni
siamo riusciti a far diventare Catanzaro
la capitale del cuore
riparato la mortalità è stata ridotta
dal 40% degli anni 60 al
4%
pensate Abbiamo
[Musica]
effettuato
Abbiamo
effettuato più di
50.000 procedure invasive in emodinamica
un numero straordinario per una regione
come la Calabria e l'agenas che è una
agenzia Nazionale indipendente una
agenzia del ministero ha collocato la
cardiologia di Catanzaro seconda dopo
Bologna con una per il trattamento
dell'infarto miocardico acuto un
successo veramente insperato e insab in
una regione come questa veramente
difficile la domanda è ovviamente che
cosa si può fare Che cosa possiamo fare
per migliorare la sanità del Sud ed in
Calabria come abbiamo abbiamo detto
tutto è difficile ma abbiamo visto che
se vogliamo vivere più a lungo dovremmo
andare in Sardegna perché la Sardegna è
la regione italiana che ha la
sopravvivenza Maggiore per le malattie
cardiovascolari Ma noi viviamo qui ed in
caso di emergenza medica Noi non avremo
il tempo per andare altrove non c'è il
tempo per andare a Milano Noi abbiamo
bisogno di curarci qui e vogliamo
curarci a casa
nostra
l'importanza dell'università EB Beh
abbiamo detto che c'è una questione
meridionale della sanità Questo era
generato dal fatto che fino a pochi anni
fa in Calabria non c'era una facoltà di
medicina
bisognava andare fuori per studiare i
bravi spesso rimanevano nelle grandi
università del centro nord sappiamo che
molte dipartimenti molte unità compresse
e di sono oggi guidate da calabresi
bravi e l'università ha
rappresentato un'opportunità per
calabresi di rimanere qui e studiare Ha
rappresentato una crescita professionale
anche per molti
ospedali certo anche l'università di
Catanzaro però deve e cambiare nei
prossimi anni bisogna perdere i criteri
dell'autoreferenzialità
e deve assumere un ruolo dominante per
quella che è la cultura sanitaria
regionale ieri il capo dello Stato ha
detto che la fuga dei cervelli sia una
scelta ma non deve essere un obbligo EB
questa regione ne ha viste di fughe di
cervelli tutti i grandi cervelli sono
fuggiti dalla
Calabria noi e voi giovani avete
l'obbligo di rimanere qui le nuove
generazioni hanno l'obbligo di rimanere
in questa regione vi è la necessità oggi
di creare una sanità Cese e
competitiva abbiamo visto che tutti
hanno un sogno oggi l'avete sentito
prima Anche io ho un sogno e il sogno
che ho è quello dei milanesi che vengono
a curarsi in in
Calabria ritorniamo e finiamo
[Applauso]
ritorniamo da dove siamo partiti non c'è
economia che tenga se non c'è il
benessere e la salute
dell'uomo dobbiamo investire nella
prevenzione Dobbiamo investire in una
cura nei grandi centri che possono
effettuare interventi impegnativi nei
grandi strutture sanitarie abbiamo cioè
bisogno di un sistema
efficace di creare i giovani medici i
giovani cardiologi del domani e di una
ricerca di qualità e quello che vi ho
fatto vedere ci abbiamo messo 20 anni
per farlo non è una cosa che avviene
subito questo modello che vi ho mostrato
è il modello che noi Possiamo e dobbiamo
replicare perché quello che vogliamo
oggi noi in questa regione è una sanità
di
[Applauso]
[Musica]
qualità